We all love open source software for a lot of
good reasons. It doesn't cost anything. It has
community support, sometimes even industry
support. But it comes with a responsibility.
One of those is making sure that it's secure. And
one of the videos that Sahdev brought us was about
the three As of open source security. Part of thatinvolved reviewing your code-- getting to know it.And so he's brought us to challenge!
That's true,Dan. So we will look at three examples of code. They're simple examples written in Golang, buteasy to understand by any developer. The beauty
of the simple code is that they represent three
areas of OWASP top ten security risk areas.
Cool!Okay, so let's take a look at our first example.
And by the way, you get to play along too. Look
for this symbol when I ask the question. And
then you'll see this symbol while I'm thinking
about it myself. And then finally, the answer
will show up [with] this symbol. So take a look
at our first one-- is about someone getting a
password. And there's this kind of the question
of security and code. So the first thing that
jumps out to me is, is when you're doing a scan,
the password is going to be shown as the person is
typing it. Now, I don't know if that was exactly
what you were after. So that's going to put down
is my first one is is don't show the password.
Right? But that might not be what you were after.
The other thing that kind of jumped out at me,
besides that, is when you say to save the
password, and this is where I was doing some
security audits myself. And they mentioned that
when you have critical data, you don't want it
ending up in logs, for example. And so here, I
wouldn't be passing around a password that is in
the clear. In fact, a smart way of doing this is,
is you run a hash on it first. Because you really
don't care about what the person's stored as their
password. You care "will the hash of it actually
match?", which is good enough for password
security purposes. The other upside is, is that
when you pass into the database, you can avoid
a potential problem where someone has inserted
things in that password that's trying to do a SQL
injection. And that's where someone is trying to
trick the program into running a SQL query that
really wasn't intended. That's the three things
I think I was talking about -- was running a
hash. Make sure... Oh! And also make sure that
the password has the keywords, er, the complexity
that it should have. And also the SQL injection.
Those are my three answers. That is my finalanswer.
Well, you did good, Dan, I must say that.So, this is an example of one from OWASP topten-- this is an example of cryptographical failure.
You never store passwords in plain text. Hashing
with salting, that's what you want to do. [Dan] Right, exactly.
And then second thing, as you said, with
complexity. One other thing is, it's not checking,
you know, at a minimum, the length of password.
The longer the password, they tend to be moresafer.
We have a bunch of videos on that topic, as
a matter of fact. So be sure to check it out. Now,
one other thing to think about is when you look at
your password and it's being stored in a database,
not just storing it in clear, at any time is both
at-rest and in-motion. That's kind of what I use
as a rule of thumb. If you have sensitive data,
you have to think about both cases. Can a DB
admin see it and can it be potentially exposed
in the logs? So that's kind of question. [Sahdev] That's
you got it. [Dan] Great. Okay, now we're going on to the
second one, which at least wasn't quite so easy.
So here we are. Now, okay, this requires justa teeny bit of explanation for Q2. And you see this permission here of 0700. For the
Unix-- people who are newer to UNIX, let me point
out what that means-- that's referring to the
[file] permissions. It's a bit pattern where each one of
these numbers represents the permissions for the
owner, group, and everyone. And so, for example,
this says that-- it's a three bit pattern --that
they have execute, or traverse rights, read and
write. That's essentially what the 7 means.
And I have to admit, when I first looked at this,I didn't really see a problem because it's saying essentially, this 700 is saying "I'm
going to let the owner be able to read, write
or traverse it", which is perfectly the legit--
and no one else can. Another common pattern you'll
see is 755 saying essentially the owner can do anything they like and the
other people can read or traverse. I had to look
this one up, and if you haven't hit pause already,
here's your opportunity to go do that and look
it up yourself. I tried to find some potential
flaws here. One thing it mentioned was the umask
capability, where you have the masking that's
applied by the operating system to a newly
created file. Though I don't know if that's
what you were after. The other possibility
is, is that there's a coding question here
because you're checking to see if
the error that came back was nil,
but it could have already existed. So that
was really, one was umask, prior existing...
And the other one? I give up. Can I phone
a friend? [Sahdev] Well, no, you pretty much got it,actually.
Really?
So the one big thinghere is every time you use any function, here Go package mkDirAll. Or using third-party packages, right, you must understand the
function before blindly using it. How it works.
So mkDirAll, it's a function that will create the
directory for you with the desired permission,
if it's not there. [Dan] Yeah, if it already exists,
it'll just leave it alone. It doesn't even return
an error. [Sahdev] Exactly. So what's missing here is "What
if there's a directory there with 0777?" [Dan] Yeah, right. In fact,when I was looking up through Stack Overflow,
there was this big argument about a potential race
condition for this, too. Because as you check to
see, is that come back in an error, and then I
checked to see it exists-- in between, potentially
someone could have come in and created that file.
And so it turns out this is actually, for such a
small problem, it's really something to look at.[Sahdev] It's a small but this is one of the, like I said,
this is the top, actually, this is the number one
problem in the top ten risk areas-- broken access
control. [Dan] Wow. Okay. So let's go out to the last
one then. And so that's question three. Okay,
so I have to comment first that I'm not really
happy with this as a code example because it
kind of offends from a few other ways besides
security that I feel compelled to point out.
One-- please don't do this where you write a
sleep loop. That's kind of a bad idea overall,
because that means that the process is
going to continue to consume resources.
It also means the process has state in
it, and if it is somehow terminated,
you've lost that state. A more proper way of doing
this is is that you should create some sort of
background daemon that you register these sleep
notifications-- I'm sorry --these notifications
with and hopefully that will do the result that
you want. I don't think that's what you're after
though. [Sahdev] That's true! [Dan] Yeah, but I felt compelled
to mention it! But I think what you're after is,
is that if you're doing this sleep notification,
especially if it's just for a longer period,
potentially the access rights to the person
you're notifying has changed in between the
time. Like imagine, for example, you're getting an
email notification coming from one of your systems
and they need authority to be able to do that.
Well, if I withdraw that authority and I have this
background process running, potentially I'm going
to be notifying them, giving them information,
leaking them information that they really don't
have a right to do. And so in this code example,
where they're in the-- coming out of this reminder
--they should check to make sure that that user
has the [authority] to do that. [Sahdev] So, you do
touch a couple of good points. But the one of
the main thing I'm looking here from security risk
areas and which is number three in the OWASP top ten: input validation
or data validation. So what are we doing here is,
we're getting the input, right? Let's say you got,10 minutes.
Now, as you said, you know, using sleep
here just for simplicity, right? Only in real
life, you know, in Golang, you may be using
Go routines. Write a trigger running, right? A
daemon running, right? And that might be running
for as long as the app is running and sending
reminders or some sort of... [Dan] You're saying, for
example, someone passes in a 1000 minutes or something like that or repetitive,
that's very... [Sahdev] That's true. Or think about it.
You want a notification every ten minutes, for example, or every one hour, right?
You make a little bit of logic change here. So, you
know, one hour for 30 days, 24 hours, or every day for the whole month.
What if somebody passed a negative value? Or
zero? We're not checking it! Instead of one hour or 10 minutes or whatever
you decide, it's going to send it instantly.
Because it's zero or negative. So that will one,
it's going to be incorrect from what your
expectation. Second is, we're logging it, right?
Depending on, like you said, the total numbers,
because there's no cap here either. It can really
use all the hardware resources, the storage. Keep
logging, logging and like instantly. And your
expectation was every hour or every few minutes
or so. But because you didn't check the input, it
can crash your system. [Dan] That's a good
point. And in fact, I would argue that if you're
looking at parameter checking, it's not a bad idea
to even check it between routines. When you're
passing-- someone's passed you a parameter --at
a minimum as an assert statement, to say "These
are what I expect as reasonable parameters."
If you want to for performance reasons, you might
have them optional at runtime. But certainly
during unit tests, certainly during integration
test and during your final testing, you want to
have every single routine test to make sure that
a state is expecting is actually legit. And in
this case, the one I got wrong, I didn't.
Yeah, this is the easy thing, but sometimes we miss it,
right? So the data validation, when it's not done
properly, it can create severe problems-- out of
bound memory. SQL injection is other thing where
because -- you can prevent it through the through
the validation. [Dan] Well, great. That was a fun quiz.
Let's go ahead and wrap that up. And I'm curious
down on the comments, I want to hear how many
did you get right and if you found anything else
that I might have missed. So there it is. Thanks
again, Sahdev. [Sahdev] Thank you, Dan. In the comments
also be sure and leave us what you'd like to see
in other Tech Talk topics. And before you leave,
please don't forget to hit Like and Subscribe.